♪♪
Narrator: TESTING THE MYTH
THAT A CAR FULL OF AIR
FRESHENER COULD BE COMBUSTIBLE,
ALLIE, JESSE, AND VALERIE
GOT A BIG SMALL-SCALE RESULT
USING A SPARK FOR IGNITION.
THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
Narrator: NOW THEY'VE MOVED ON
TO THE SECOND SCENARIO,
A SLOWLY LEAKING CAN
WITH A LIT CIGARETTE.
Allie: EVEN BUSTER DOESN'T
LIKE CIGARETTES.
Narrator: THEY'VE BEEN WATCHING
AND WAITING
FOR ALMOST TWO MINUTES
AND THAT'S LONG ENOUGH.
-THAT DIDN'T WORK AT ALL.
-MNH-MNH.
BUT WE DO KNOW OUR AIR
FRESHENER IS FLAMMABLE.
Narrator:
THE RATIO OF AIR TO FUEL
IS CRUCIAL FOR COMBUSTION.
WORKING ON THE PREMISE
THAT THEY DIDN'T LEAK
ENOUGH AIR FRESHENER,
THIS TIME THEY START THE SPRAY
A FULL MINUTE BEFORE IGNITION.
LIGHTING IN THREE, TWO, ONE.
[ OBJECT WHIRS ]
Narrator:
THE LIGHTER IS WORKING,
BUT SO FAR NO BOOM.
WELL, MAYBE IT'S TOO WET
IN THERE.
MAYBE IT'S TRYING TO COME ON,
BUT SINCE IT'S SO WET,
THEN IT'S NOT ABLE TO.
I THINK WE SHOULD KEEP TRYING
AND EVERY FIVE SECONDS
TRY IT AGAIN, JUST TO SEE
IF IT WILL DRY UP AND EXPLODE.
-THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
-SOUNDS GOOD.
Narrator: BY LETTING THE SPRAY
DISPERSE AND SETTLE,
THEY'RE HOPING TO DIAL
IN THE PERFECT EXPLOSIVE RATIO
OF FUEL TO AIR.
AND JUST A FEW CLICKS LATER...
-OH, MY GOD!
-OH, MY GOODNESS!
-GEEZ!
-WHOA!
THAT WAS OUT OF NOWHERE!
OH, MY GOD. OH, MY GOD.
-OH, I FELT IT.
-OH.
THAT WAS SO AWESOME.
I WAS LITERALLY JUST ABOUT
TO SAY, "IT'S NOT WORKING."
Narrator:
IT'S A SAFE BET THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT VALERIE WAS THINKING, TOO.
BOOM, THE TOP FLIES OFF,
AND VALERIE IS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD, MY HEART."
I THINK IT SCARED HER.
YOU WOULD STARE AT IT FOR, LIKE,
10 SECONDS, AND YOU'D LOOK AWAY,
AND AT THAT EXACT MOMENT,
IT WOULD EXPLODE.
MORAL OF THE STORY?
DON'T EVER TURN YOUR BACK
ON SCIENCE,
ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT'S AN EXPLOSION.
-THAT'S SO PRETTY.
-OH, MY GOD.
Jesse: LOOK AT THE LID.
OH, MY GOD, AND RIGHT
AT THAT MOMENT
WAS WHEN MY HEART DROPPED.
YEAH.
RIGHT THERE WAS WHEN I HAD
A HEART ATTACK.
WAH.